you taught your Dad
recently
why give us a
call
hey so where did you appear
[Music]
from Oklahoma
I've never been Anywhere But
[Music]
Here what were you doing with that big
girl get a lot of crazy ass foreigners
mostly how's it going
again this here is Jackie hi she needs a
job say she'll do anything yeah you like
guns not really what the [__] you doing
here
then a bit more powerful in a punch
H [__] yeah call me when it's
done what is this
place huh you don't
understand get back in the
car they found a
body Le I keep got your hands
full don't regret this
will just need to fight
back I'm going to tell them everything
you ever did FBI open up are you
threatening
me
yep that was really stupid
honey
I never for
[Music]
okay